while some movies are universally
acclaimed others we can all pretty much
agree are just garbage but then there's
a third category films that inspire both
adoration and disgust blockbusters and
split audiences completely in half this
phenomenon spans all genres but these
films all have one thing in common
they're movies everyone either loves or
hates Forrest Gump when Forrest Gump hit
theaters in 1994 it grossed 677 million
dollars worldwide and won six Academy
Awards it elevated Tom Hanks from actor
to superstar and many of its iconic
lines are still quoted today it's
currently ranked on IMDB as the 12th
best film of all time and has a 95%
audience approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes but for all the love Gump has
received it's picked up some haters too
[Music]
it caused a huge upset when a beet pulp
fiction for best picture at the Academy
Awards many right-wing news outlets have
lauded Forrest Gump is one of the best
conservative films of all time but to
put it simply critics feel the movie is
all melodrama with no real message while
fans love it for its simple perspective
of a complicated world life was like a
box of chocolates you never know what
you're going to get Titanic sailing into
theaters in 1997 Titanic became the
highest-grossing film of all time
the epic period piece became a major
cultural touchstone inspiring everyone
who's ever been on a boat to shout the
iconic line
I'm king of the world
hey somebody has to do this I'm King
don't ruin a perfect week
it's beautiful costumes tragic romance
and revolutionary special effects
touched so many moviegoers that Roger
Ebert wrote an entire essay about how he
could hear the warmth in people's voices
when they discuss it and see the light
in their eyes but critic Owen gleiberman
says the film gave rise to hater culture
for every enthusiast there's a cynic who
feels the film is too cliche and that
its theme song my heart will go on
should only be played for prisoners even
Kate Winslet herself said the song made
her want to throw up
how often do you listen to Celine Dion's
my heart will go on people have also not
been able to let go of the fact that
Jack absolutely could have fit on the
door with rose instead of freezing to
death in the ocean he just should have
tried harder to get on that door because
I totally enough room right but for the
most part fans think the film is
romantic perfection by all the haters
just think it's romantic fluff at least
everyone can agree on the romance angle
though you know however noble Jack's
intentions might have been sometimes
discretion is the better part of valor
the passion of the christ'
deadpool may be the highest-grossing
r-rated film worldwide but when it comes
to the domestic box-office The Passion
of the Christ is the king of kings the
biblical gorefest
earned 370 million dollars at home which
is largely thanks to Christian
moviegoers some congregations rented out
theaters for special screenings while
others actually screened the film in
their churches the faithful are flocking
to this theater this morning the passion
is playing on all 20 screams one man was
so passionate that he bought six
thousand tickets and gave them away for
free but many people saw the movie as
anti-semitic for its murder hungry
mobster portrayal of Jews along with the
fact that director Mel Gibson refused to
have any Jewish scholars advise him on
the subject matter
audiences were also shocked by the
film's extreme violence it was very
graphic gray its pigma graphic but it
was probably true to life considering
the subject material it's no wonder
audiences either hailed Gibson as a
cinematic saint or crucified him for his
controversial film No Country for Old
Men
in 2007 the world was introduced to
Anton Chigurh one of the most iconic bad
guys in movie history what's the most
you ever lost an acquaintance sir the
most you ever lost a coin toss No
Country for Old Men won four Academy
Awards including Best Picture and was
hailed as one of the Coen Brothers best
movies
it is currently ranked by IMDB as the
159th best film of all time but a lot of
people couldn't get past the movies
ending the hero dies the bad guy gets
way and after Tommy Lee Jones chats
about his mysterious dream the movie
cuts to black for those who were
expecting a conventional finale it's one
of the most infuriating movie endings of
all time leading man Josh Brolin knew
the ending was going to tick people off
and told MTV I love that people leave
the movie saying I hate the ending I was
so pissed good it was supposed to piss
you off
the Dark Knight Rises The Dark Knight
Rises was surrounded by so much hype
that fanboys and Christopher Nolan
himself were defending it before it even
hit theaters in 2012 when film critic
Marshall fine posted the first negative
review his website crashed under the
rush of angry responses Rotten Tomatoes
eventually had to shut down the film's
comment section a first in the website's
history despite a spirited defense from
hardcore fans the film has been picked
apart for plot holes and logical
inconsistencies moviegoers were also
upset with the film's ending which
showed Bruce Wayne alive and well and on
vacation with Selina Kyle some thought
the movie was a critique of the Occupy
Wall Street movement while others
suspected that Bane was a metaphor for
Republican presidential hopeful Mitt
Romney calm down doctor now is not the
time for fear
Locke comes later inspiring everything
from death threats to devastating
takedowns The Dark Knight Rises as
Nolan's most hotly-contested movie to
date Man of Steel depending on who you
ask Man of Steel is either the best
Superman movie or the worst Zack
Snyder's depiction of Superman as a
cynical complex and tortured hero stood
out in stark contrast to the colorful
and quippy films Marvel had been
cranking out many fans appreciated this
somber take in the film earned 668
million dollars worldwide however many
fans preferred Christopher Reeves
cheerful and fun version of Superman to
this dark and gritty approach others
were horrified by the sheer volume of
collateral damage' mastering Superman's
duel with General Zod but perhaps the
biggest controversy came when the Man of
Steel straight-up murders his enemy a
move that seemed to go against Clark
Kent's strict moral code even producer
Christopher Nolan initially opposed the
ending which producer David s Goyer
revealed on the Empire film podcast
killing Zod was a big thing and that was
something that Chris Nolan originally
said there's no way you can do this the
murder made it into the film and sent
the Man of Steel in a direction that not
everyone was happy with lala land
when lala land danced into theaters it
won over audiences and critics alike
it's also tied with Titanic and All
About Eve for earning the most Oscar
nominations ever 14 in total audiences
far and wide were touched by this movie
musical homage and love letter to
Hollywood which was written and directed
by Damien Chazelle however for every
la-la-land fan there's a cynic rolling
their eyes many were annoyed by Ryan
Gosling's sebastian who was portrayed as
the white saviour of jazz genres that
was pioneered by black musicians dying
man it's dying on the vine and the world
says let it die it had its time not my
watch others felt Emma Stone's character
Mia was far less complex than her male
counterpart ultimately lala land was a
movie made for the ones who dream but
for many people that dream was a
nightmare mother when it comes to
polarizing his audience director Darren
Aronofsky has outdone himself with
mother an allegorical horror film that
traps Jennifer Lawrence in a
never-ending nightmare of strangers with
no respect for personal space the film
was not for everyone scoring a middling
69% on the tomato meter and an
audience score of 50 percent while
horror fans enjoyed how gruesome and
bloody it was others argued the film was
too heavy-handed with its allegories and
symbolism needless to say with the way
mother divided its audience it might be
the very epitome of a love adore hated
film the last Jedi when Rey tracked down
Luke Skywalker in the force awakens fans
around the world couldn't wait to see
what would happen in the next Star Wars
film two years later the last Jedi
caused a great disturbance in the force
directed by Rian Johnson it quickly
became one of the best reviewed films of
the franchise with some critics hailing
it as the best Star Wars film since the
Empire Strikes Back
fans praised the film for subverting
expectations demystifying the Jedi
mythology and paving a new path for the
franchise however many Star Wars fans
saw the last Jedi as an attack on George
Lucas's original universe while the film
scored a 91 percent approval rating on
Rotten Tomatoes its audience score
currently sits at only 47 percent the
biggest upset seems to have to do with
Luke Skywalker whose portrayal as a
moody pessimist upset even Mark Hamill
who played him I think the world of Rian
Johnson I said to him I totally disagree
with what you think about Liu then again
audiences weren't too pleased with the
Empire Strikes Back when it was first
released either maybe in a few decades
fans will look back on the last Jedi
with a little more fondness too bright
described on deadline as lethal weapon
Meets Lord of the Rings bright
unfortunately did not live up to any of
the hype surrounding it the Netflix
original movie which was written by max
Landis and directed by David Ayer was
universally hailed as a total mess from
its sloppy world-building to
cringe-worthy dialogue not even Will
Smith's charisma could save bright from
scoring and abysmal 26 percent approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes ferry lives
don't matter today somehow though its
audience approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes currently sits at 85 percent
Netflix president Reed Hastings said
bright was one of the site's most viewed
original titles ever and a sequel is
already in the works for whatever reason
plenty of people watched bright which
seems to be the only aspect of the film
that anyone can agree on thanks for
watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]